OUTRAGEOUS ACCUSATION THAT HE
INCITED A DEADLY ATTACK ON A
MOSQUE.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH NBC WALKING
BACK ITS BIG STORY TODAY, THAT
THE FEDS HAD WIRETAPPED THE
PHONES OF THE PRESIDENT'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN.
THE STORY NOW HAS A LENGTHY
CORRECTION ON TOP SAYING THAT
THAT REPORT, BUT THE CORRECTION
EXPLAINS THAT THEY WERE
MONITORED BUT NOT WIRETAPPED.
AND INVESTIGATORS DIDN'T
ACTUALLY LISTEN TO HIS CALLS.
WELL, FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED
THAT AT LEAST ONE OF HIS PHONES
RECORDS PHONE NUMBERS DIALED AND
THE LENGTH OF THOSE CALLS
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY G
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY U
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY I
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY N
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY S
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY O
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY T
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY D
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY W
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY N
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY T
AND RUDY JULIE            RUDY E
REPORTS SAME, WE THINK IT'S
UNTRUE BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
TOTALLY ILLEGAL.
DISCLOSING A WIRETAP IS ITSELF A
FEDERAL FELONY.
ALL OF THIS CAME AFTER GIULIANI
EMPHASIZED THAT THE TRUMP TEAM
WILL KNOW LONGLEY COMIC MONGERS
SIT IDLY BY WHILE MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION CREEPS INTO EVERY
ASPECT OF THE PRESIDENT'S LIFE.
>> THIS STARTED WITH THE
COLLUSION OF THE RUSSIANS.
NO.
NOW THEY GO TO OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, COLLUSION AMONG THE
PLAYERS.
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY TRYING TO
DO IS TRAP THEM INTO PERJURY AND
WE ARE NOT SUCKERS.
>> Laura: LET'S GET INTO
TODAY'S DEVELOPMENTS WITH
WHITE HOUSE SECRETARY ARI
FLEISCHER, AND A FORMER FEC
CHAIRMAN, BRADLEY SMITH.
GUYS, WE HAVE SO MUCH TO GET
THROUGH.
I WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST,
BRADLEY.
THERE WAS A MOMENT DURING THE
INTERVIEW THIS MORNING WITH RUDY
GIULIANI, WHERE HE AGAIN
REITERATED THAT THIS WAS NOT A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION, AND THEN
HE ADDED ANOTHER THOUGHT THAT
SEEM TO CONTRADICT THE FIRST
THOUGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IF WE HAD TO DEFEND THIS AS
NOT BEING IT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION, I THINK WE COULD
DO THIS.
THIS WAS FOR PERSONAL REASONS,
THIS WAS THE PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
HURT PERSONALLY, NOT POLITICALLY
HURT PERSONALLY, NOT POLITICALL
POLITICALLY.
AND THE FIRST LADY, BY SOME OF
THE FOLKS' ALLEGATIONS.
THAT ONE FALSE ALLEGATION WAS
SIX YEARS OLD, AND I THINK HE
WAS TRYING TO HELP THE FAMILY.
FOR THAT, THE MAN IS BEING
TREATED LIKE SOME KIND OF
VILLAIN AND I THINK HE WAS JUST
BEING A GOOD LAWYER.
IMAGINE IF THAT CAME OUT ON
OCTOBER 15, 2016, AND THE MIDDLE
OF THE LAST DEBATE WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> SO TO MAKE IT GO AWAY, CALL
ME MADE IT GO AWAY, HE DID HIS
JOB.
>> Laura: BRADLEY, DO YOU SEE
MY POINT THERE, IT WAS ALL
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
WHETHER IT WAS THREE WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION OR TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION, I WASN'T
QUITE GETTING THAT PARTICULAR
POINT.
AND WHETHER IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF ANY SEC
VIOLATIONS.
SPEAK TO WRITE, I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT RUDY WAS THINKING,
BUT THE BASIC LAW ON THIS IS,
MANY THINGS THAT CAN INFLUENCE A
CAMPAIGN OR NOT IT CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURES.
SO IF THE CANDIDATE THINKS, I
WOULD LOOK GREAT IN THAT NEW
SUIT, HE MIGHT SPEND $1800 ON A
SUIT, BUT IT'S NOT A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE.
IF HE THINKS, I WOULD DO BETTER
ON THIS GRUELING CAMPAIGN, IF I
HAD A WEEK AT MARTHA'S VINEYARD
FIRST, NOT A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE, PERSONAL
EXPENDITURE.
THE RULE ON THIS IS NOT THAT
SOMETHING RELATED TO THE
CAMPAIGN IS A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE, IT'S SOMETHING
RELATED TO THE CAMPAIGN AS A
CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURE.
THE SEC REJECTED THOSE.
THAT HAS TO BE AN OBLIGATION
THAT WOULD NOT EXIST BUT FOR THE
CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THERE IS A STRONG
ARGUMENT AT LEAST FROM WHAT WE
KNOW PUBLICLY WHERE TRUMP WOULD
HAVE SAID, WE WOULD HAVE MADE
THESE PAYMENTS.
CELEBRITIES WOULD HAVE MADE
THESE KINDS OF PAYMENTS.
HE WOULD HAVE REASONS LIKE,
PROTECTING HIS FAMILY,
PROTECTING HIS COMMERCIAL
VIABILITY, NOT WANTING THE
DISTRACTION.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT MIGHT
HAVE MADE HIM WANT TO DO IT.
THEY HAVE MADE SIMILAR PAYMENTS
IN THE PAST, AND EVEN STORMY
DANIELS IF WE ARE TO BELIEVE HER
SAID IN HER "60 MINUTES"
INTERVIEW THAT IT IS AS FAR BACK
AS 2011 SHE WAS TOLD NOT TO SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS, SUGGESTING
THAT LONG BEFORE HE WAS A
CANDIDATE THEY WANTED TO KEEP
THIS QUIET.
I THINK THERE'S A VERY STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS NOT A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION, WHETHER
COHEN PAID IT AND TRUMP
REIMBURSED HIM OR WHAT, BUT IT'S
NOT A CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURE.
>> Laura: DOES IT ALL GO TO
THE STATE OF MIND OF
DONALD TRUMP, WHEN HE WAS
REIMBURSING, DURING WHAT TIME
FRAME, IS NOT RELEVANT HERE TO
LOOK AT THIS?
BECAUSE AWAY BRADLEY JUST
DESCRIBED IT, I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THE WAY OF COURSE IT'S BEING
REPORTED ACROSS MOST MEDIA
TODAY, IT IS BURNED DOWN THE
HOUSE KIND OF STUFF.
YOUR REACTION?
>> Bradley: WELL I WOULD NEVER
BURN DOWN THE HOUSE FOR THIS
KIND OF CAMPAIGN LAW VIOLATION,
ASSUMING IT IS ONE.
THIS IS NOT THE CRIME OF THE
CENTURY, ITS RELATIVELY SMALL
POTATOES.
BRADLEY IS MORE OF AN EXPERT ON
THE ELECTION LAW THAN I AM AND I
ALWAYS THOUGHT THE TEST WAS, IS
IT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INFLUENCING THE CAMPAIGN?
SO IT'S ALWAYS A QUESTION IF YOU
DO SOMETHING 11 DAYS BEFORE THE
CAMPAIGN, BUT IT'S RELATIVELY A
FACT QUESTION.
AND BY NO MEANS WOULD BE EASY TO
PROVE.
BUT AGAIN, IN THE GRAND SCHEME
OF THINGS, IT'S RELATIVELY
MINOR.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY PRESIDENT
BEING IMPEACHED, MUCH LESS
PROSECUTED FOR A FELONY FOR
THAT.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE FACT THAT
RUDY ISN'T REALLY TALKING ABOUT
IT IN A VERY INTELLIGENT WAY AND
THAT IT'S VERY DANGEROUS TO GO
ON TELEVISION AND START TALKING
ABOUT WHAT YOUR CLIENT SAID AND
DID.
>> Laura: REGARDING IW
>> Laura: REGARDING IN
>> Laura: REGARDING IT
>> Laura: REGARDING IO
>> Laura: REGARDING IP
>> Laura: REGARDING IA
>> Laura: REGARDING IY
>> Laura: REGARDING IF
>> Laura: REGARDING IR
YOU A MONTAGE THAT MEDIA COM DID
ABOUT THIS WIRETAP ISSUE.
WATCH.
>> THEY WERE ABLE TO GET TEXTS,
EMAILS AND WIRETAPS ON HIS MANY
PHONE LINES, LEADING UP TO THE
RATE AND CONTINUING.
>> IF YOU ARE INVOLVED IN A
CONSPIRACY, CRIME OR DIRTY
TRICKS.
>> OR COVER-UP OR OBSTRUCTION.
>> IF THERE IS EVIDENCE OF THE
CRIME, I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE
THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER.
YOU GET THE SAME TREATMENT I DO,
YOU GO TO THE JUDGE AND SAY, I
WANT TO LISTEN TO HIS PHONE.
>> WELL IT TURNS OUT THAT THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN AND YOU WONDER WHY
PEOPLE CALL IT FAKE NEWS.
THEY WERE POSITIVELY JUBILANT
ALL DAY, LIKE WE WILL HAVE THE
RECORDINGS, WE WILL BE ABLE TO
THE SPECULATION ABOUT WHAT THE
CONVERSATION MIGHT HAVE BEEN IF
TRUMP ACTUALLY HAD A
CONVERSATION, I HAVE NEVER HEARD
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS MEDIA
FEEDING FRENZY?
>> Ari: THE WHOLE DIRECTION OF
THE PRESS HAS BEEN BLAMING
DONALD TRUMP FOR EVERYTHING.
WHEN NBC HEARS ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, THEY HAVEN'T
EXPLAINED HOW AND WHY THEY GOT
IT WRONG.
THEY RUN WITH IT AND, CNN, MSNBC
AND CBS HAVE NEVER EXPLAINED HOW
THEY PUT A STORY ON THE AIR
SAYING MULTIPLE SOURCES READ A
MEMO SAYING THAT
DONALD TRUMP JR. HAD ADVANCED
NOTICE OF THE WIKILEAKS.
NOW THEY HAVE TO RETRACT THAT
BECAUSE A PERSON READING THE
MEMO GOT A DATE WRONG AND THE
NOTICE WAS AFTER THE WIKILEAKS
WAS AIRED.
BUT THEY NEVER EXPLAIN HOW THEY
POSSIBLY ALL COULD HAVE HAD
MULTIPLE SOURCES GETTING THAT
STORY WRONG BECAUSE THIS
THRESHOLD IS SO LOW FOR
ANTI-TRUMP STORIES.
AND IT'S HURTING JOURNALISM,
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS AMERICA
SPLITTING INTO TWO, FRANKLY.
YOU HAVE THOSE WHO DON'T BELIEVE
THE PRESS AND OTHERS WHO HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT HEALTHY FOR THE
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE THE PRESS GET
IT WRONG.
>> Laura: AND BY THE WAY, THE
ATTORNEY FOR STORMY DANIELS WAS
INVITED ON THE SHOW BUT HE
DECLINED.
HE WAS ALSO OUT THERE SAYING,
THIS IS A FACT.
I NOTICED THEY ARE TREATING HIM
LIKE HE'S JUST AN OBJECTIVE
ANALYST, WHETHER IT'S ABOUT THE
LAW OR WHAT HAPPENED.
HE KEEPS SAYING, IT'S A FACT.
AND YOU SEE THESE JOURNALISTS
STROKING THEIR CHIN, IT'S A
FACT.
OF COURSE IT WASN'T A FACT, IT
WASN'T A FACT, IT WAS IN EFFECT
AT ALL.
>> Ari: THEY TREAT HIM THE WAY
THEY TREATED ADAM "PRESS PLAY"
SHIFT.
THEY HAVE NO CYNICAL TOUGH
QUESTIONS ASKED.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GO TO YOU
ON THIS OTHER DEVELOPER THAT WE
LEARNED TODAY.
THE EMAIL THAT MICHAEL COHEN
USED TOO I GUESS FACILITATE OR
FINALIZE THE DEAL WITH THE
PAYMENT TO DANIEL, WAS A
Trump.org EMAIL.
DOES NOT HAVE ANY BEARING ON
THIS CASE AND WILL NOT BE LOOKED
AT BY MUELLER, WHO WE KNOW --
AND WE WILL GET INTO THIS IN THE
NEXT SEGMENT -- WE KNOW CAN BE
OVERZEALOUS AND PUSHES THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE LAW TO GET
SOMETHING HE WANTS.
IT'S NOT FIRST TIME IT'S
HAPPENED.
WE SAW THAT WITH THE BLOOD GOYA
VEG CASE.
SPIVAK OF COURSE, I CAN'T SAY
WHAT MUELLER WILL DO.
BUT IF IT'S NOT A CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURE, IF IT WASN'T AN
OBLIGATION THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
EXISTED BUT FOR THE CAMPAIGN,
THEN IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW IT
WAS PAID.
IT WOULD HAVE TO COME FROM
SOMEPLACE ELSE.
IN FACT THIS IS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS.
IMAGINE IF THE TRUMP FOLKS HAD
PAID FOR THIS WITH CAMPAIGN
FUNDS AND REPORTED THIS AS A
CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURE.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU, AND YOU CAN
BET THE FARM, THEY WOULD HAVE
FILED COMPLAINTS ALLEGING THAT
THIS WAS AN ILLEGAL DIVERSION OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR PERSONAL USE,
AND THAT IS THE PROBLEM THAT YOU
HAVE HERE.
SO EITHER THEY WILL GET THEM
COMING OR GOING AND IF HE SPENT
HIS CAMPAIGN FUNDS, THEY WOULD
SAY YOU CAN'T SPEND CAMPAIGN
FUNDS FOR THAT, IT'S PERSONAL.
IF HE SPENDS PERSONAL FUNDS THEY
WOULD SAY, THAT HAD TO HAVE BEEN
TO BENEFIT YOUR CAMPAIGN AND
THAT'S ILLEGAL, IT CAN BENEFIT
BOTH.
>> Laura: LET'S MOVE ON TO
MONITOR OF PERHAPS TEXT
MESSAGES.
WHO WAS BEING TEXTED, NOT THE
CONTENT BUT WHO WAS BEING
TEXTED.
AND IT, MONITORING OF COHEN'S
PHONE CALLS.
TO WHOM WAS HE SPEAKING?
SO NOT THE CONTENT, BUT THE LOG
OF THE CALLS.
IS THAT SURPRISING TO YOU,
UNUSUAL TO YOU, OR WHAT WOULD
THAT INDICATE THAT MUELLER
BELIEVES?
>> IT'S ACTUALLY -- FIRST OF
ALL, REMEMBER THIS IS A SOUTHERN
DISTRICT ISSUE, NOT A MUELLER
ISSUE.
BUT IT'S RELATIVELY STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE AND YOU
DON'T NEED PROBABLE CAUSE FOR
THAT.
YOU'VE SEEN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY, AND BY THE WAY, ON
THIS NBC THING, IF NBC HAD
TALKED TO ANYBODY WHO IS
KNOWLEDGEABLE ON CRIMINAL LAW
AND WHITE-COLLAR CASES, HE WOULD
HAVE IMMEDIATELY SAID, THAT
CAN'T BE RIGHT.
THAT STORY CAN'T BE RIGHT
BECAUSE GIULIANI IS RIGHT ABOUT
THAT, IT'S A CRIME TO LEAK
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S INCREDIBLY SERIOUS, MORE
SERIOUS THAN LEAKING GRAND JURY
INFORMATION.
I KNEW THE STORY COULDN'T BE
RIGHT WHEN I HEARD IT.
WHY DIDN'T THEY CHECK WITH
SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT CRIMINAL FEDERAL
LAW BEFORE GOING WITH THIS?
>> Laura: THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT, WHAT IT FINDS HOWEVER,
IF IT FINDS SOMETHING AND ALL
THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT THEY TOOK
FROM MICHAEL COHEN'S VARIOUS
PLACES OF RESIDENCE, AND
ANYTHING RELATED TO RUSSIA OR
TEN
TANGENTIAL TO THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, THAT COULD BE
USED AS A PROXY TO GET
INFORMATION FOR MUELLER, RIGHT?
>> IF YOU ARE CYNICAL, YOU COULD
USE IT AS A PROXY.
ALL THIS TIME, I'M A LITTLE
CYNICAL ABOUT THIS.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Laura: I AM A FORMER
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DF
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DA
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DT
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DR
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DE
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DY
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DA
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DD
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DY
DEFENSE PROSECUTOR            DU
ARE A FORMER PROSECUTOR SO YOU
KNOW.
>> IF I COME ACROSS SOMETHING
THAT IS EVIDENCE OF A CRIME AND
IT'S IN MUELLER'S VALLEY WICK,
GOES BACK TO EVIDENCE.
BUT YOU LOOK AT WHAT NUMBERS YOU
ARE DIALING, HOW MANY TIMES ARE
THEY TALKING TO THIS PERSON, BUT
THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY GETTING
THE CONTENT OF THE MESSAGE.
>> Laura: SOLD THEY SAY AFTER
HIS OFFICES WERE RAIDED, HE MADE
A PHONE CALL TO A WHITE HOUSE
NUMBER, THEY CAN PUT THE SCREWS
ON COHEN AND ASKED TO WHOM DID